So what the last one?
>> So we're going to do in the last one.
I probably shouldn't go through
all the grungy details.
Though all the all the pieces that you
need for this have been stuff that I've
said but what we're trying to do now is
represent this value function vaz of t.
Applied to belief state B and we said
that was going to be basically a dot
product of the belief state with
some kind of reward vector for
the current action plus a weighted
version of the value function for
the previous time step.
So it's going to be helpful to
actually take the value function of
the previous time step and
write it out more explicitly.
So this is basically just
expanding on the definition
of the state estimator that
we did in the previous slide.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We're going to say that the value
according to the t minus one
time step value function.
For the belief state that we
get from taking action a,
and making observation
z from belief state b.
We can write this out as the maximum.
Overall vectors in that set of
the dot product of that vector with
the resulting belief state which we had
previously derived to have this form.
Okay, the observation function times
the transition function times the belief
state and then normalized and this
normalization factor is the probability
of making the observation z given that
we are in belief state band action a.
This is a highly non-linear function but
this is the awesome part ready, since
we're going to ultimately multiply this
value function times the probability
that z is the actual observation.
In other words probability
of z given b comma a.
This and this end up canceling and
we're left with is an actual
linear transformation.
So this this weird divide by thing that
actually makes things really yucky
cancels itself out.
So convenient.
>> [LAUGH] Just like life.
>> Not usually, but math sometimes does
this for us and so at the end of the day
we end up with a quantity that is a dot
product with the belief state and
another quantity that is a dot
product with the belief state.
We can factor out the belief state and
what it leaves us with is a giant vector
one for each combination of observation,
action, and which gamma is going to
be the maximum at that observation.
So we actually have to
take the product of
the number of vectors that was
in the t minus one set raised
to the number of observations
times the number of actions.
And that's going to be the maximum
size of the set that we get for
representing the t step value function.
So like you said, could could blow up.
But still finite.
Can't block to be infinite
if it started out as finite.
>> Nice, so that feels like
a prove with induction to me.
>> Great, okay and so
you wouldn't want to actually do this.
There is code in burlap for
doing a lot of these processes,
there's also my
collaborator Tony Cassandra
created a program called POMDP-solve
that you can download that does all
these calculations carefully and,
you know, on your behalf.
So I didn't really want to get this
to the point where you could actually
necessarily code all this up, just
to believe that it's code upable and
you can use an existing implementation
If you want to actually run.
>> It very mathematical of you.
So there's one more step before
we can get something that I mean
you can actually implemented this way
but this is guaranteed to be exponential
because you're actually combining
all these things together.
There's one step that we can
do that if it's the case
that the Q functions have
a small representation.
Then the algorithm will run quickly.
>> All right.
>> Here, it could be that the Q
functions are actually very very big.
In case it's not obvious, the Q
functions are represented right there.
>> Yeah.
>> I called it va sub t.
But that's really the Q function.
>> I like it.
I like it.